il y en a aussi qui se disent est-ce que
les familles ont envie de voir le visage
de de de de de cette voilà de cette
principale suspecte on dit ça voilà ou
de celle du bourreau de de leur fille
voilà et et voilà et c'est vrai que
quand on voit ces images on a encore
plus de colère
on se dit voilà c'est c'est c'est
incroyable et des réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui c'est aussi cruel pour ça
parce que c'est vrai que quand on voit
ça c'est vrai que moi ça ça va voilà
c'est c'est quand on se dit que cette
cette jeune femme quelques heures après
quelques jours après elle va commettre
cet acte barbare et que elle a fait des
vidéos en faisant la
[Musique]
imaginez pour la famille cette vidéo va
vous demander qui ont circulé toute la
journée et on le voit la voie en train
de danser en train de cesser alors
c'était avant le drame mais on peut pas
s'empêcher de penser à ça
regardez ce qu'elle postait sur ses
réseaux sociaux et donc c'est le visage
de la princesse suspect donc qui est des
qui a été dévoilé aujourd'hui sur les
réseaux sociaux sur BFM et chez nous
regarder
dans un instant bon c'est voilà c'est
Mathieu ben moi j'ai mis non mais là
j'ai mis non parce que d'abord le
premier raison pour la famille je pense
qu'effectivement je pense je l'ai bien
qu'effectivement si j'étais la famille
j'aurais pas du tout envie de mettre un
visage sur
là je parle plus du côté BFM mais
qu'est-ce que ça amène
journalistiquement puisque normalement
maintenant elle est sous les derrière la
barreaux donc ça veut dire que si elle
est pas derrière elle n'est plus un
risque pour la société donc qu'est-ce
que BFM a très bien fait
c'est une information journalistique
déjà et BFM la donne
c'est la France est suspendue à ce drame
depuis des heures des jours entiers BFM
à l'information et à le visage de la
principale suspecte
je suis désolé
BFM ne doit pas se poser la question une
minute ils doivent dévoiler le visage de
de de de de de de de voilà du présumé
d'A présumé coupable je suis désolé
c'est un élément de moquette c'est même
pour tous les gens qui suivent notre
émission qui suivent les chaînes
d'information qui suivent BFM qui
suivent c'est nous qui suivent c'est un
élément très important et aussi pour
l'opinion publique parce que on met un
visage et pourquoi c'est vrai que quand
on voit ses vidéos on se dit comment
cette femme a pu commettre un acte aussi
barbare c'est la bataille c'est des
vidéos tout à fait banales qu'on trouve
chez plein de personnes de Tik Tok
regardez j'en ai une deuxième et c'est
ça qui est grave
[Musique]
pourquoi on monte ces images pourquoi
BFM a montré ses images c'est juste pour
montrer que c'est personne tout à fait
normal qui met des vidéos que tout le
monde poste sur les réseaux vous rendez
compte si on avait vu ces vidéos avant
qui peut imaginer qu'elle va commettre
l'acte à la commis après
Raymond personne qui peut imaginer
qu'elle est folle toi tu penses que BFM
va bien bravo BFM je suis contre les
vidéos qu'on diffuse quand il y a la
présomption d'innocence qu'on n'est pas
sûr mais j'en ai marre qu'on défende
toujours à chaque fois on dit Intel
c'est fait tuer par machin on montre le
visage de la personne qui est morte et
on protège celui qui a tué moi celui qui
a tué je veux pas qu'on le protège je
veux qu'on monte son visage je veux
qu'on sache qui c'est quand il va en
prison je veux je vais je vais être cru
et je vais être honnête je veux qu'on
lui pourrisse la vie si on peut lui
pourrir la vie en montrant son visage on
lui pourrit sa vie il va assumer et à
chaque fois si on le reconnaît dans la
rue si quand ils sortent de prison on
sait que c'est lui on lui montre sa vie
à partir du moment qu'il y a des
meurtres comme ça des crimes comme ça
abominables pourquoi on devrait le
protéger pourquoi on devrait pas montrer
sa tête si c'est 15000 euros l'amende on
paye on paye les 15000 euros on fait une
cagnotte à ton père
avec l'accord de la famille de
récupération
montrer le visage de la voir ça va je
pense même que la famille non non en
vrai elle est partagée elle a envie de
voir aussi le le visage du du bourreau
de de sa protéger c'est horrible mais
c'est le terme pourquoi protéger ces
personnes là dites les termes moi je
parle français je le dis le terme je
veux pourrir la vie de ces gens-là
partout quel âge je veux qu'on lui dise
c'est pas toi il y a 5 ans c'est pas toi
il y a 10 ans c'est pas toi
de cet exemplaire je parle de gens je
parle de gens qui ont fait des crimes et
ils vont sortir de prison après on cache
les noms de ces gens là
dessus donc quelques minutes bien
entendu en direct sur face à Baba
regardez une autre vidéo pour vous
montrer le profil parce que aussi ça
nous montre le profil
ça nous fait encore plus flipper parce
qu'on se dit mais des vidéos comme ça on
envoie des milliers sur les réseaux
sociaux pour nos enfants
il faut dire ne suivre ne suivez
personne même une jeune femme qui a
l'air plutôt même normal jolie jeune
voilà il faut suivre personne
c'est effrayant
[Musique]
voilà donc le visage de la principale
suspecte c'est des BFM qu'il a dévoilé
en premier c'est très bien et c'est vrai
que
quand on voit ça c'est c'est
vrai quand on voit ses vidéos on est
encore plus meurtri et on se dit que
c'est incroyable que cette jeune femme
est plus commettre cet acte Gilles oui
mais vous avez prononcé le mot normalité
banalité quelqu’un comme les autres
c'est pour ça que ces vidéos sont
fondamentales et là je vais m'avancer ça
n'engage que moi mais il y aura tout un
débat sur la responsabilité pénale quand
on voit ses vidéos on se dit et c'est ça
qui est encore plus brutal c'est une
jeune femme comme les autres comme il y
en a plein et tout ça comment elle
a-t-elle pu faire ça et on a
l'impression qu'elle est comme toutes
les jeunes femmes elle s'habille elle se
maquille elle met de la musique donc
peut-être que ça aura un sens pour après
la faire c'est à dire que peut-être que
ça permettra qu'elle soit jugée parce
que c'est pour ça
on les met ce soir et pourquoi je dis
bravo à nos amis de BFM d'avoir mis le
visage
cette femme qui est la principale
suspecte on parle depuis quelques jours
de
cette peut-être hypothèse quelle serait
déclarée irresponsable ça c'est un gros
élément de l'enquête parce que pour
faire des vidéos comme ça c'est des
vidéos tout à fait normal on voit
qu'elle a et ça ça peut jouer sur
l'enquête ça peut jouer auprès de la
justice et nous le plus gros drame qui
pourrait y avoir pour nous ce serait
qu'elle soit déclarée responsable donc
il y a pas de procès et ça je pense que
BFM a eu raison de le montrer parce que
BFM en faisant ça il montre que c'est
quelqu'un n'a pas l'air du tout
irresponsable il y a tous les éléments
qu'on comptait
je suis désolé Gilles
ça donne un sens énorme à l'affaire
c'est des vidéos fondamentales les les
experts psychiatres vont se jeter sur
ces vidéos excusez-moi mais là encore
une fois ça n'engage que moi elle
respire la normalité oui mais donc après
si jamais elle était même sur Linkedin
c'est-à-dire que c'est une vie sociale
c'est exactement voilà voyez ou pas en
plus de restauration alors là ils ont
flouté voilà c'était tout à l'heure
voilà mais c'est vrai que tout ça c'est
des éléments de l'enquête et c'est des
éléments qui feront peut-être qu'elle ne
sera pas jugées irresponsable ce que
tout le monde que tout le monde craint
que tout le monde redoute on se trompe
moi de bâti quand on dit ça non non
c'est clairement j'imagine ce que ce que
ce que la famille craint qui est pas qui
est pas qui est pas de procès que soit
je gérer responsable donc c'est c'est le
moment comme ça de toute façon ce qui
est sûr c'est que le magistrat
instructeur et les experts psychologues
et psychiatres vont exploiter ces
éléments là ils vont comment ça va se
passer l'ouverture d'une information
judiciaire il y a des actes d'enquête
qui sont qui sont commis pendant cette
affaire et parmi les actes d'enquête le
magistrat instructeur a recours à des
experts psychologiques et psychiatriques
qui vont auditionner la mise en examen
et en plus de l'auditionner il va y
avoir une exploitation des téléphones
exploitations de l'ordinateur et donc ça
va
aujourd'hui donc vous quand des médias à
forte audience comme BFM comme nous on
diffuse ça ça va faire partie l'élément
de l'enquête des éléments de l'enquête
ça c'est vraiment la responsabilité pour
le coup de chaque rédaction si elle
estime que ça apporte une pierre à
l'édifice au débat public à
l'information générale pour les
concitoyens français ils peuvent la
diffuser en tout cas rien ne si ne s'y
oppose et maintenant sur sur l'enquête
en elle-même le magistrat instructeur
aura d'ores et déjà accès au téléphone
accès aux informations il y a eu des
perquisitions il y a eu des saisies il y
a eu des scellés donc le magistrat
instructeur et les enquêteurs ont déjà
accès à toutes ces pièces là qui m'ont
exploité surtout le long de la formation
travail de notre émission c'est
d'informer aussi d'apporter des éléments
sur une affaire dont on a énormément
parlé une affaire qui nous bouleverse
tous les jours et c'est vrai que moi je
trouve voilà je dis
nos confrères de BFM ont eu pour moi la
bonne réaction oui évidemment que c'est
une bonne chose déjà parce que lors des
réseaux sociaux tout sort donc si les
gens bien sûr à la télé ils essaient de
voir sur les réseaux et puis les
affaires aujourd'hui elle se déroule
aussi en direct dans les médias et le
fait qu'il y ait des gens des millions
de personnes qui voient le visage de
cette femme ça peut être apporté aussi
de nouveaux témoignages de gens qui
l'ont connu qui vont exactement
témoigner et apporter plus
d'informations sur elle donc non
seulement c'est un scoop et en plus ça
peut permettre de faire avant qu'elle
enquête donc bravo à BFM
Gilles a de nouvelles infos sur
l'entourage de la suspect et les raisons
qu'il aurait peut-être fait vriller
comme ils comme ils ont dit c'est Lord
c'est leur expression oui alors lors de
sa garde à vue la présumée coupable quoi
voilà cette femme a été entendue quatre
fois il y a eu quatre auditions donc ça
on le sait aujourd'hui et dans ces
auditions les policiers
qui d'ailleurs eux-mêmes Cyril tient les
policiers qui ont découvert le corps qui
suivent l'affaire ont une assistance
psychologique tellement ils ont été
marqués par la scène et bien les
policiers ont une assistance
psychologique absolument absolument et
bien lors de sa garde à vue elle ne
manifeste pas de signe d'émotions quand
on lui présente les photos et elle dit
mes parents à elle sont morts sous mes
yeux j'ai été violée ça ne me fait rien
et bien on s'aperçoit dans la
déconstruction de son discours que c'est
faux elle n'aurait pas été violée et
puis ses parents ne sont pas morts sous
ses yeux elle a passé son enfance à
Alger dans un quartier populaire une
famille pauvre et puis après on retrouve
des traces d'ailes dans le Val-de-Marne
notamment à Bry-sur-Marne où elle habite
sa mère meurt d'un cancer et c'est à
partir de là que sans doute ça bascule
elle devient fragile et son entourage
décrit une personne qui commence à
changer et qui commence à être perturbé
donc maintenant les enquêteurs vont
tenter de savoir si effectivement dans
ce profil psychologique il y a une
fragilité qui est née mais les premiers
témoignages montre quand même encore une
fois ça n'engage que moi quelqu'un qui a
été structuré qui allait dans des cafés
à Bry-sur-Marne qui avait vous le disiez
qui était sur les réseaux sociaux qui
avait une vie sociale donc quelqu'un qui
n'avait pas l'air déséquilibré à un
moment il y a une faille dans sa vie il
y a quelques jours il y a une faille
elle change c'est plus proche disent
elle change pourquoi bien entendu
personne dans son entourage proche n'a
plus prédire ce qu'elle allait se passer
mais pour le moment on n'a pas
l'impression que cette personne était
déséquilibrée très franchement